a la vida es como un surtido de galletas
y todos empezamos comiendo nos las de
chocolate después pasamos a las que
están rellenas de crema y finalmente
siempre queda esa galleta que no sabe a
nada
es cierto nadie quiere comérsela pero
alguien debe hacerlo para acabar con el
surtido es un deber moral tirar la caja
a la basura sin habérsele ha terminado
no es propio de américa hillary es esa
galleta si nadie sabe a ciencia cierta
lo que defiende probablemente no será la
mejor presidenta de los eeuu
pero está en política desde antes de que
jordi hurtado salir en televisión y al
igual que el presentador de saber y
ganar ella tampoco ha envejecido
tus amigos americanos tenéis que votar a
hillary clinton porque qué narices
porque es hillary clinton porque vas a
terminar votando la y lo sabes
hillary for america comete la galleta o
será el monstruo de las galletas quien
nos comerá a todos